there's only one way to get truly truly
rich and financially wealthy in the
sport of fighting and that's through the
UFC all people say is well the UFC is
making this much so therefore they
should be sharing that with the fighters
the employees but if you look at other
organizations they're not as profitable
because they're not as good of a product
it'll reinvest into building the entire
sport so you're saying like Bellator
might pay a larger percentage of their
revenue to the fighters but there's just
less Revenue there's almost no revenue
and there's no almost no reinvestment so
I was the big name in Bellator for the
last 5 years I was there my last five
fights I had a camera on me one time I
came to the UFC in the first 6 months
they were flying out to my house to do
this little piece and follow me the UFC
countdown they reinvest hundreds of
millions of dollars back into the sport
of mix marshal arts and that Rising tide
has raised All Ships pfl Bellator one
Championship everyone else yeah